if you were trapped more than 65 000
feet below the Earth's surface what
would you do you found out your dead
mother is alive deep within the Earth's
core at the bottom of this Abyss
everything is trying to kill you and
you'll have to go through a terrifying
Village hidden Within the Ruins of a
secret City in order to get one step
closer to finding your mom I'm going to
break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat the Golden
City in made in Abyss season two this
girl has no idea that she is about to be
hunted by an immortal monster Rico reg
nanachi and their dead friend pruska now
turned into a white whistle have finally
reached the entrance into the sixth
layer in search of Rico's mother they've
gone through hell to get here and now
they think they're finally safe but they
have no idea what Horrors await them
down in the sixth Lair they reach this
strange underground lift when suddenly
it starts descending deeper and deeper
through this underground ocean it breaks
through this sea of Bones and Frozen
corpses and the gang prepares for what's
to come finally the lift passes through
a layer of light as it enters the sky
from above Landing in this fossil
infused Golden City where they'll never
be able to return from they explored the
mysterious ruined City and wonder who or
what built it not realizing the truth is
more horrifying than they could imagine
they begin to explore and Rico gets too
excited but nanachi says that they need
to focus on setting up a camp they have
no map for this place and no way of
knowing where this place leads to they
see different animals and peaceful
monsters in the distance then they come
across this nest and go steal its eggs
but that's when nanichi Hears A noise
from back outside and they go to check
it out and that was their biggest
mistake all of a sudden they see a giant
Fireball form in the distance causing
horrifying meteorites to come crashing
down on them poison gas then starts to
emit from the crash sites as more and
more Fireballs come raining down on them
and the gang runs for their sweet lives
whoa okay these kids have been playing
with fire for far too long and it's a
basic that nothing worse has happened to
them they have so far traveled six
layers deep into the Earth's core which
means that's a long freaking way down
into the Earth since they began this
journey with only just Rico and reg and
they've gotten lucky with Rico simply
getting a minor brutal injury along the
way and during their Journey on the way
down they bumped into this furball
nanachi who lost her best friend down
here and also kind of sorta nanochi did
ask rake to vaporize her best friend on
purpose so there's that and also they
had to survive bondra the novel in order
to get down to the sixth Lair a place
where only the best and a few wide
vessels have ever gone to but if that's
the case and they finally made it to a
place where only a few of the best of
the best have gone then why are they
acting so stupid this sixth layer of the
Abyss is absolutely horrifying from this
point on it is physically impossible to
return to the surface unless you're reg
and this place is known by white
whistles as the last die as a no
explorer that has gone down here has
ever returned to the surface which if we
compare to real-life diving kind of
makes sense as ascending from a d deep
deep real underwater dive quickly can
lead to decompression illness however
trying to ascend within the abyss will
provide you with the most horrifying
death all because of the Abyss curse
which means these guys are stuck here
within the sixth layer and to top it off
there are creatures here of absurd to
extraordinary levels of danger and to
top it off there's these poisonous
geothermal vents that can rain down
Hellfire upon them they knew it was
dangerous to travel down here and
they're traveling with reg a relic from
the abyss of Unknown Origin this means
that Rico and her gang should have been
playing it way more carefully from the
get-go and should not have rushed into
exploring too much of the area without
first properly taking into account their
surroundings in this case my advice for
these kids could have been similar to
those lost in the woods they should have
stopped and moved with only the purpose
of finding shelter and a potential water
source at least for the first night then
they should have carefully started to
explore the nearby surrounding areas and
take detailed accounts of what they see
around them nearby which would have been
a much more useful undertaking and could
have allowed them to more accurately and
more methodically take notes as to what
Horrors or beauty they could have seen
down here because at this point writing
down everything they see hear or smell
will prove to be insanely valuable for
future generations of white whistles who
may make it down here Rico's team was
moving way too fast and way too Carefree
in this type of happy-go-lucky attitude
will soon get one of them killed they
managed to outrun the fireball death
area and then decide to send a letter
back to the top layer of the Abyss to
let their City know that they're still
alive but in the sixth layer nothing can
escape but then try to send off this
letter in this makeshift hot air balloon
but these flying creatures suddenly
destroy it as it ascends into the air
Reagan nanachi begin to worry if this is
a sign for things to come but Rico
shrugs it off and mentions that they
should all head to bed not realizing
that they're being watched in The
Distance by this mysterious creature the
same creature that will kill everyone in
a matter of days they wake up the next
morning as Rico realizes in shock that
her white whistle pruska is missing they
then come across this Left Behind
drawing and realize that someone snuck
through Rex defenses and stole it while
they were sleeping the gang then decides
to track pruska down as reg tries to
follow its scent along the way they find
these two crudely made stuffed toys
filled with their hair freaking them out
and giving them the creepy feeling that
these were left for them on purpose they
track some Footprints as they cross over
this bridge and into a building-like
structure there they notice the same
symbol near the Dory that was on the
drawing from earlier they suddenly find
this entrance that is blocked by
forcefield Gathering their courage they
head through it and discovered the most
delicious things ears Jaws ribs arms
practically every part of the human body
hanging by strings attached to the
ceiling walking through to the end of
this tunnel they discover a whole
village full of these weird terrifying
looking creatures this red dragon
looking thing then approaches the gang
and introduces himself Rico then
nervously asks if they took her white
whistle prushka and red dragon says that
they are working on it and he tells them
to follow him they follow this creature
up these stairs and red dragon leads
them into the shop where they see a
creature chiseling away at Rico's white
whistle causing her to freak out but red
dragon says that prushka wants this and
that once the whistle is made into its
true form it will then become stronger
and increase its value red dragon then
explains that he and every human in here
is a hollow a type of creature just like
nanachi someone who survived the sixth
Lair of the abyss and whose body has
become deformed as a result he leads
them into a busy shopping street and
Rico discovers a page from her mom's
long-lost notes she is shocked and picks
it up and the shop owner quickly demands
that she must pay for it first red
dragon then tells Rico that she can
trade parts of herself that has value
for her mom's page he then tells her
that she could trade her eyes skin and
even fat for her mom's page and that
that's how this whole village currency
system works it works on value Rico is
horrified and red dragon then tells her
that human children like her have the
most value around this Village and that
he'll be willing to pay anything to own
a part of her okay this is absolutely
horrifying because somehow this entire
Village lies within this small structure
and everything seems sophisticated
enough to have restaurants in at a
system of currency what this crazy red
dragon is basically saying is that this
Village's main industry is based on
trading on a concept of value meaning
the villagers here are constantly
trading and bartering for things of
equal or higher value this is all
self-determined by whoever is in
possession of them as well as by The
Village deity itself everything is based
on the importance of the item it has to
the owner however the freaky part about
all of this is that children here are
considered to be of insane value by
everyone which means Rico here could
sell parts of herself and NAB some heavy
coin in the process but unlike what red
dragon said Rico could play it smart and
not be into her feelings and tell this
guy that she'll get back to him on that
about what she's willing to sell because
truly the value of her mom's notes is
high since this is Rico's mom we're
talking about the same month that Rico
spent all this time trying to search for
down here and getting her mom's notes
could provide some valuable insight into
her mother's life however selling a part
of Rico's flash wouldn't serve her well
because ew This Village has one flaw
that I think Rico could use in order to
play this shop owner since the part of
the value system relies on perceived
value and she is a human child Riku
could find a piece of herself that isn't
too important and could go hype up its
importance and the value of it in order
to make it seem like it's a higher value
than it actually is the mind is a
powerful tool and her high value along
with a little bit of Plucky salesy
attitude could let her trick this
Merchant into thinking she's selling him
something of insane value when in
reality all she could be selling him is
a lousy paperclip or whatever else [ __ ]
of value that she has on her person if
Rigo is smart she could consider taking
this Merchant up on his offer but alter
the deal and take some time and plan on
how to play this game on her terms
instead shocked Rico then angrily
demands that nobody touch her that she
is going to get to the bottom of the
Netherworld the gang then decides to be
sneaky and to get more information about
this Village from all the residents
since they still haven't mentioned who
stole their white whistle red dragon
then leads them through the village and
reveals the most insane thing it tells
them that everyone here used to be
explorers just like Rico and had dreams
also of reaching the bottom of the Abyss
but because of the harsh environment
their bodies changed into Hollows by the
curse of the abyss and as a result they
could never leave from here they then
hear a piercing scream as this black
creature shows up and offers the
citizens pieces of Flesh and items of
value to sell or use for pleasure red
dragon then tells Rico that within this
world inside this portal they came
through this city is protected by a God
that protects and supports everyone
inside here the mysterious God then
gives Rico some cold hard koi as a
result of the God punishing one of the
hollows that played a little too roughly
with Rico's pet red dragon then says
that they can use that to buy food and a
place to rest oh they have no idea the
horrors that are going to come their way
later Rico feels sick and decides to
rest So Reagan nanachi go to do some
exploring they run into red dragon again
and they hear a terrifying noise outside
of the portal crowds quickly begin to
form as everyone heads for the portal
entrance red dragon then tells them that
all of these people are Hollow here are
coming to see a terrifying female
creature known as faputa an immortal
being that can travel anywhere in the
abyss except through this portal nanichi
then thinks that papita is the one who
stole Rico's white whistle and she asked
reg to go check it out near the entrance
of the city reg then heads through the
portal and sees a Sinister figure
sitting on top of a mysterious robot
this is faputa princess of the hollows
suddenly this creature attacks reg and
asks him what happened to his arm reg
then has a crazy flashback of this girl
and he thinks that somehow he knows her
from his past should then calls reg by
name confirming it however because of
reg's memory loss since Rico first found
him he doesn't remember anything okay we
gotta be careful are we gonna die this
is a beast that was born out of sheer
pain and torment this creature is known
as the princess of the sixth layer and
can travel anywhere in the sixth Lair
except through this portal and still
from what we can see she's still
basically a child this Beast is immature
as hell and is the definition of
unstable this coupled with her powers of
speed basically telepathy and insane
strength makes her a batched case a
fluffy apocalyptic craziness she's kind
of cool though I'm not gonna lie but the
fact of the matter is this case of crazy
says that she knows our rake is a good
thing that means we have at least some
leverage over this creature but the bad
thing is is that this kid rek is
suffering from a case of memory loss
likely caused by some sort of head
trauma as if we remember back in the
first season Rico found reik confused as
hell and alone near the surface from the
looks of things rake seems near and dear
to fapata even though the situation is
tense we can tell that she Khan has a
thing for our boy at least in a friendly
way this is why I would try and leverage
the truth with fiction and tell fabata
that we lost our memory up near the
surface of the abyss and where we also
met Rico who saved us however I would
also spill a little bit of [ __ ] and
say that an enemy that we fought near
the surface took most of our memory
promise and left us near the service and
that the only way to get our memory back
is by teaming up to stop this made-up
enemy you see where I'm going with this
this light would make Rico look good in
fact his eyes since she saved us and
would also keep them safe and buy
everyone here sometime until we figure
out more about the situation like one
figure out how to kill fapata or to
figure out how to escape from the
strange sex Lair hellhole and continue
on our journey down into the abyss
because encountering a fluffy little
master that looks good enough to pet but
is able to rip us in half is a really
scary concept and it is not something
that we should sign up for to deal with
suddenly Papa engulfs reg and takes him
to her cave there she reveals that
they've met before and then gets a
little too friendly with her sniffing
causing reg to freak out and leave back
within the portal to the Village nanichi
finds out from Red Dragon that her best
friend from the abyss that died long ago
is actually alive and within the
possession of someone in this Village
horrified she forces red dragon to guide
her to where this creature is located
they enter this dark cave and come
across this horrifying serpent Skeleton
thing and it reveals to nanachi her old
friend from the abyss a hollow just like
nanachi and someone who she saw die with
her very own eyes shocking nanachi to
the Bone back outside the village rake
bumps into fapita's Iron Giant bodyguard
and he offers to guide him back to the
village on the way Iron Giant tells rank
that it thinks he was created by the
same person who made all of these robots
he mentions that all of these robots
were designed to maintain order and
placed in all layers of the Abyss
however he's lost all contact with the
other robots since way back and doesn't
know how many of them are still left not
having access to his past or knowing who
or what he is the Iron Giant encourages
reg to go find out his origin story and
track down who or what made them back in
the village Rico asks this one creature
where it thinks Reagan nanachi went and
it tells her that most likely they went
snooping near the edge of the village
telling Rico that the secret to this
Village lies down in this tretch along
with something horrifying lurking
beneath the surface Rico heads down into
the trench along with a weird friend
that she picked up during her time in
the village the same one who played a
little too roughly with her pet from
earlier and got its insides and all of
its stuff ripped out of its butthole by
the God of this place great choice Rico
down there they discovered this strange
human-like person chained up and
surrounded by these strange black worms
she introduces herself as voyko and Rico
asks if she might know where her friends
are located she tells riko that she has
a deep connection with this Village and
knows where one of them may be Fuego
reveals to Rico that the origins of this
Village are horrifying and mentions that
she tried to put a stop to it long ago
but as a result got imprisoned in this
hole Rico then breaks voico free and she
takes her to the location where nanachi
is worried that the village folk might
find out that she's escaped she tells
Rico to go through this door alone and
in there she finds something horrified
she discovers that nanachi has sold
herself to this red-eyed skeleton snake
thing in exchange to set her long lost
friend free she carefully approaches the
creature and that was her biggest the
red-eye skeleton snake thing tells Rico
that because she's a child she holds
incredible value and says that it would
be willing to let nanachi go if Rico
sold both her eyes both legs or half of
her organs inside of her that's
delicious okay whoa this is crazy
because this red-eye skeleton snake
thing is known around here as one of the
top dogs one of the three sages and his
personality is the type is that he will
do whatever it takes to get what he
wants even if it means destroying his
own body in order to get it picture a
rat knowingly getting stuck in a rat
trap in order to taste a small piece of
cheese that's what this guy is I.E a nut
job this creature the nanachi enslaved
herself for is known as midi years ago
midi and nonichi were both humans and
best friends who transformed into these
creatures as a result of this guy Bond
Rude the novel doing horrifying
experiments on them in the abyss however
the real midi died in the first season
so long story short red eye skeleton
snake thing basically used his magical
Voodoo powers and created his own
version of midi down here the fact is
that midi turned into an immortal
creature as a result from those
experiments this means that she cannot
really die and this is what allows red
eye skeleton snake thing here to
constantly feed on her flesh and never
run out of food because nananchi is such
a darn good best friend her selling
herself to this guy means that he must
have found her even more valuable than
midi herself and knowing this guy's
personality the horrifying offer that he
presented to us is one that he will
probably not back down from but here's
the crazy thing because we know that
living without both eyes or both legs
could be problematic however this dude's
offer of taking half of all our organs
as horrifying as it may seem is entirely
possible as only five organs are only
truly necessary for our survival the
brain heart liver one kidney and one
lung the bare minimum but even if that
is optional kind of and with 78 organs
in total in the entire body this means
that you could live without things like
your gallbladder but if you wanted to
get even weirder in theory surgeons
could remove your lower spine larynx
tongue butthole and if you want to be
supported by machines in an intensive
Care Unit you could even live without
your skull so red eye skeletons offer
here means that there are thousands of
horrifying ways to skin this cat however
I'm not looking for this guy to put his
creepy paws on me oh no no no no no I
would therefore suggest a trump card and
in this case it would be eat my [ __ ]
hear me out now your toilet takes the
bare end of your bottom on The Daily so
don't complain there are many more uses
for your [ __ ] than you may realize the
methane contained inside your [ __ ] can
be used as transport Fuel and to heat up
homes and you can use it as fertilizer
and if that didn't tickle your bottom
enough the scientists of the University
of the west of England have created a
device that can generate electricity
from pee that's right folks the
experiment had a urinal be contained
with microbiofuel cells which are filled
with live microbes that feed on urine
and through the biochemical imagery
through that microbe's use it converts
this into electricity the point is is
that we could tell red eye skill to
snake thing here that while he can take
any of our tasty organs we can offer him
a way to produce electricity for the
whole village and even show him various
ways that he could use our own pee and
poop and we could even say that we had a
wicked case of IBM yes to swing the deal
take that red-eye skeleton snake thing
eat my [ __ ] Rico is horrified at her
choices and is about to accept red eyes
skeleton snake things off her when she
is suddenly stopped by nanachi who tells
her to leave as the red-eye skeleton
snake thing drags her out of the room
outside she begs Fuego if there's
anything else she thinks that he can do
but that's when they hear a horrifying
Rumble nearby they go to check it out
and see this horrifying monster vuego
tells her that since the villagers can't
leave the village they lure animals and
monsters into their Village and hunt
them this way but this one is too great
and begins destroying everything in its
path Rico then runs to go collect her
whistle and find out that the Jeweler
has made it stronger than ever they see
all these Villages show up prepared to
fight this monster and defend their
Market from being destroyed Rico begs
the villagers to let her join and they
all group up together to take down this
monster approaching the market this
Beast charges at them and prepares to
devour them all when riko and red dragon
lure it into this trap in this open area
the villagers then light this mofo on
fire and manage to capture this beast
but suddenly it tries the last move and
this forces Rico to blow on her new
powerful white whistle this temporarily
disables the creature and suddenly reg
shows up from out of nowhere all powered
up from her white whistle reg tells Rico
that he could feel the wide whistle
calling to him and it telepathically
told him what Rika wanted him to do
using this information Rico uses her
white whistle to direct reg into
destroying this creature once and for
all after Rico asks this red-faced guy
on how she can save nonichi but that's
when he reveals the most horrifying
thing he tells Rico that if she can
Harvest a piece of apoptus Flesh this
offering instead might convince red eye
skeleton snake thing to let nanachi go
later a horrified Rico feels Reagan on
the situation with nanachi and he tells
her that he'll go back to meet with
fopita first and talk things over he
then leaves as Rico asks voiko what
exactly fabata is and how she's
connected to voico and the village so a
very very long story made somewhat
shorter Fuego tells her that she was
once part of a group of outcast
explorers who believed that there was a
golden City located deep within the
abyss however during their Journey
Through the sixth layer they discovered
that the environment was too harsh to
survive and everyone got sick from the
water that they drank which turned their
bodies into horrifying Abyss monsters
however during their darkest moment they
found a wish granting a which one of the
relics told them could help save them
all if the person making the wish was
from a child since children had the
strongest imaginations and their
emotions was the closest thing to the
source this is why out of desperation
the survivors asked this girl irumui a
tribal girl that they found at the very
beginning of their journey and they
asked her to use the egg to save them
all but the wish went horribly wrong and
the little girl turned into a monster
forced to give birth to a child every
day that would die mere moments after
being born the group then discovered
thanks to red face guy that eating the
Flesh of the dead babies was the key to
saving them all then one day before she
died irimiwi turned herself into a
self-sustaining village where their
survivors could live inside of her
forever however before dying she gave
birth to a final baby and this baby was
faputa since that day farpata has vowed
to destroy the village for what they did
to her mother okay this is terrifying
basically what happened here is that
these ragtag group of explorers came to
this island long before there was even a
thriving City up above in search of the
mystical Golden City that they thought
was located at the very bottom of the
Abyss but the environment and the
wildlife was too harsh and people
started dying in desperation they ended
up using irumui to save themselves by
giving this little girl a magic Relic
that turned her into basically the abyss
Monster version of Noah's Ark they were
all going to die because of the cursed
water that they all drank but irumui
turning herself into this Village still
wouldn't have solved their food problem
so what did they do redface guy
butchered each and every single one of
irami's children and fed it to everyone
whether they were unconscious or not
this group of explorers did try to boil
the water but that didn't work so what
they should have done next then would
have been to boil the water again and
then collect the steam water from the
boiling water this will make the water
even cleaner and even safer ideally to
drink basically they should have just
turned their drinking water into
distilled water they had add the gear
and the knowledge and they even had
robots that they could have used to help
and by them doing this this will help
further ensure that the diseased-filled
body morphing cursed water that they
found in that cave that's filled with
particulates that they talked about
wouldn't stay in the water that they're
drinking ideally now we don't know how
resistant to heat these particulates are
but drinking steam water is way safer
than just drinking their boiled water
which clearly they found out didn't work
and also this red-faced sky here was
their leader and basically the one
calling the shots he was the one who
butchered irimiri's children if I was
Rico and rank I would work on finding
out some way or some proof to
incriminate him and reveal it to fapata
and tell her that he's really the one to
blame because us being in the middle of
all of this drama means that we are
guilty by literally Association to all
of these villagers and us trying to
leave the village and fudging all of
this likely wouldn't work either as we
likely get brutally slaughtered by
fabatub the moment we set foot outside
of The Village's fortified perimeter
where fapata could easily get to us the
most pressing matter that we have is
figuring out how to stop bhopta or
director Russian to someone that isn't
us since their problem has now become
our problem later reg returns to Rico
and tells her that he's convinced fopita
to cut off one of her arms and that they
can now use this to exchange it for
nanichi and free her however the sight
of the arm shocks the whole village
boyko asks Rey how did he manage to
convince fapata to cut off a piece of
her arm but reg hesitates to tell her he
says that in exchange for her arm fapata
wants him to destroy the village
forcefield in order to let her enter and
kill everyone the whole village is
shocked and red face guy discovers
Fuego's disguise Rico then asks red face
guy if he's actually using her and
Reagan nanachi to help him and his
villagers one day escape from this
Village prison and to continue on their
Journey down into the abyss red face guy
doesn't deny it but he tells her that
it's her choice to decide on what fate
will become of everyone here suddenly
they hear a terrifying Rumble from
beneath their feet and then another
monster draimo one of the three sages
burst through the ground it's here to
kill and take fabata's missing arm Farm
reg then leads the monster away as red
face guy grabs voyko and forces her to
watch the horror unfold he then tells
her that this monster is actually a
guardian and it only comes out when the
village is under threat Greg tries to
outrun the monster but it blocks all the
exits and has him cornered suddenly reg
hears voiko yell out that the monster is
not here to steal the arm but to kill
them reg looks around helplessly as he
sees this monster about to devour all of
his friends with no options left reg
uses up the one move that he has and he
fires his hand Cannon right at this
Beast blasting a horrifying beam of
energy right through its body destroying
everything in front and behind it
vaporizing a hole right through the
protective force field around the
village that was his biggest mistake
everyone here looks in horror at what
Reg has just done reg then tells riko
and the villagers to hide before papata
gets here and kills them all he tells
the villagers that since he used his
last Cannon he will soon pass out for a
couple of hours and won't be of any help
to anyone suddenly everyone screams in
horror as they see in the distance The
Immortal princess of the hollows
declares that she hasn't forgotten what
these villagers have done to her mother
and will brutally murder every single
person here this happy and monster then
tries to attack papata but she easily
defeats it later reg finally wakes up
and he sees fabata brutally tearing
apart all of the villagers one by one
and she bathes in their blood he finds
that Rico and a few of the villagers
have managed to hide and wait it out but
it won't be long until she finds them
having nothing left to live for the
villagers reg then decide that it's up
to them to stop faputa so Rey goes up to
her prepared to die for the cause he
tries to convince her at first to change
her mind but fabata says no Rico then
blows her white whistle and this gives
Rey extra powers and he uses them to
confront papata during the fight papta
finally reveals the true story of how
she and reik met she tells rake that
she's met him before down here on the
sixth layer and that over time they
formed a bond and in her opinion fell in
love papata tells rag that he promised
to help her destroy the village once he
returns from the surface Rey is shocked
and fopita gets angry at him for not
remembering anything okay this is really
really bad because right here is in a
[ __ ] show of a situation and needs to
handle this delicately if they want to
have a shot at not letting whapata kill
them all now we know from what she told
us that Rey and her were tight and
possibly a little too close if you know
what I mean and we've seen countless
examples now where faputa has proven to
be the one with the bigger balls and has
demonstrated that she can clearly
overpower us at almost every level this
is why instead of acting like a broken
record reg should avoid fighting with
her and should stop being so dang
aggressive just like when confronted
with an aggressive dog rake should have
handled this situation more calmly and
should not try and fight fire with fire
since he'll likely lose and only make
her more mad and since they've already
had a pass together even though he
doesn't remember it fahapata likes him
and he should use this heart instead of
his fist to handle her he should try to
charm her feelings into making her
submit and use whatever sweet honey to
wear he can use to play like a fiddle
and make her chill out because being
such a stud womanizer right now is the
only thing that he can do in order to
save the gang himself and make fabata
realize that Vengeance never solves
anything unless you're me then it
totally works across this hill the gang
waits for reg to come back but they are
shocked when fapata comes back holding a
passed out rank with nothing holding
this fluffy killer back now papita
prepares to kill Rico and everyone else
here but suddenly she gets swatted away
by none other than red-eye skeleton
snake thing and anonichi which by the
way red eye skeleton snake thing's real
name is bailoff but I never bothered to
tell you that until just now I'm sorry
turns out ever since fapata entered the
village red eye skeleton snake thing
decided to let nanachi go and team up to
stop their common enemy fopita angry as
hell papita charges a red-eye skeleton
snake thing just as he tries his final
trick on her he releases a burst of his
inner memory smoke as his body starts to
crumble away to nothing which causes
vaputa to see into his memories and see
how kindly they treated fopita's mother
and how guilty they all felt at
surviving on the Flesh of irimiui's
children papata then collapses to the
floor more confused than ever said only
this giant Beast blasts through the
village along with other terrifying
animals from the sixth layer of the
Abyss the villagers realized that since
the village force field is broken
there's nothing now to stop these
horrifying Monsters of this place from
entering to consume their flesh it's a
bloodbath and fapita watches as the
people she once wanted to kill for so
long get brutally murdered and ripped
his shreds all around her she tries to
stop these beasts but she gets
overpowered and gets torn up a lie
barely able to stand fopto collapses on
the floor suddenly the surviving
villagers come to her rescue and begin
feeding her their body parts giving her
enough strength to regenerate and come
back to life and take on the six lair's
most terrifying creatures red dragon
takes Rico's gang and their surviving
villagers to safety as they come across
red face guy whose real name is wazukyan
and the former leader of the villagers
and this guy is about to die he says
that he fell down here earlier with
voiko and that she's missing dying right
here they then hear fapata calling for
the villagers to now return to her
finally coming to terms with they
wronged her the villagers agreed to go
back to fapata on the way they find
voiko but discovered that because of the
destruction of the village force field
the curse of the Abyss has transformed
her into a horrifying monster and that
if any of the villagers attempt to leave
and get outside the force field they
will disappear into nothing rescuing her
they finally reach fopita and try to
help her Rika blows on her white whistle
again empowering reyk to find more of
these beasts again just as she collapses
gaining a footing in the fight papata
then tells everyone here that in order
to stop these monsters she needs to
destroy this entire Village but to do
this she needs to consume the villager's
flesh and souls in order to reach her
maximum strength the villagers then
accept their fate as red dragon takes
Reiko nanachi and a few others to find
cover and the entire structure begins to
come crashing down on the powered up
papatoeto destroys this hollow Village
causing the entire thing to come
crashing down even more killing all of
the monsters inside as Reiko and gang
take cover nearby on the way out they
find a depleted fopta and rescuer and
red dragon donate his soul into fabta
saving her from time voiko now horribly
cursed and on the verge of death tells
fopta about her child mother in her last
moments and then she too finally kicks
the bucket now with everyone that she
loves is gone reik convinces to join
their team and despite him not
remembering their past together Greg
somehow charms papita again into saying
yes Enrico even gains her mother's
missing notebook page now the whole team
then prepares to continue their
Adventure down even further into the
abyss and hopefully one day find Rico's
mom and if you want to get further into
six layers don't forget to like comment
subscribe and check out the how to be
playlist down below